[Musique]
voir petit ami
nounours nous sommes arrivés qui est
content bordeaux oh oui pas trop
à la campagne au à la campagne qu'elle
calme je sens que je vais enfin pouvoir
écrire en paix mon merveilleux livre les
mémoires d'un lourd et bien bon travail
nous j'ai cours mon inspiration
n'entraîne pas trop le hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop
cornichons je crois que ce jour n'est
pas assez sec pour tresser ton panier
mais oui dédain j'ai cueilli quand la
lune descendait
tient une visite à très haut mes amis
quel plaisir de vous retrouver dans
cette paisible campagne nous nous étions
prêts au jour vieux camarade pepita
pipita bien vu nous nous crée là mes
amis je ne suis pas venu pour vous
déranger mais tu ne dérange pas non je
ne suis pas venu pour jouer mon pauvre
année vous n'êtes pas malade non je
cherche seulement un peu de tranquillité
pour travailler
oh [ __ ]
c'est bien contacter voie autre don
cherry et votre travail amis voilà voilà
chers dada je m'installe là et je dis
bonjour à mon ami pépites à ce que j'ai
dans ma page ce n'est pas une araignée
au moins
du miel meurent super [ __ ] je sens que
ce miel va me donner des forces pour
travailler
non je suis ici pour travailler au
travail
non il va écrire si ça lui fait plaisir
notre ami va écrire un livre les enfants
allaient jouer au dehors il a besoin de
calme
merci data vous êtes un affreux bon
alors on s'envoie vient comme mischa
ceux qui sont gentils ces petits dino
oui si tu as besoin de quelque chose tu
nous appelles oui merci
bon j'en étais à le ciel était à l'orage
les lions avaient faim
que veux-tu pepita au la jolie fleur je
suis gâté minutes ali au nom c'est un
long travail que d'écrire un livre
[Musique]
wallet vous chers amis
juliette à mon manuscrit malheureux veut
voyant julietta
cher nounours nous craignez vous pas que
votre patron s'impatiente oui merci amis
je me retire cornichons je te confie mon
manuscrit prend en grand soin d'akon
nous les deux sur la table
au revoir pepita au jeu sans concède
cette fierté calme campagne je vais
enfin pouvoir écrire
bonne nuit
adoma
dans mon petit cornichons d'or vite
[Musique]
elle est un régal et on livre nounours
n'avance pas trop il avance au premier
allant en route
bonne nuit les petits ça aide pour 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
bon
[Musique]